anschlag auf bundeswehr in mali zwölf
deutsche soldaten werden verletzt
teilweise schwer
plötzliche gefahr am himmel ein tornado
im süden tschechiens tötet und verletzt
menschen und richtet riesige schäden an
und schluss mit der massentierhaltung
deutschlands größter discounter will weg
vom billig fleisch ein impuls für
weitere ketten meinen experten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem freitag
norbert lehmann ist auch wieder dabei
für den sport ein wunder und der familie
er gilt als gefährlichster
auslandseinsatz der bundeswehr die
beteiligung an der un-friedensmission im
westafrikanischen krisenstaat mali jetzt
wurden dort zwölf deutsche soldaten
durch eine autobombe verwundet drei von
ihnen schwer der anschlag war gegen ein
nachtlager der vereinten nationen in der
region gerichtet zurzeit sind etwa 900
soldatinnen und soldaten der bundeswehr
vor ort sie unterstützen die seit acht
jahren dauernde un-mission saß bohnsack
berichtet
aktuelle bilder vom anschlagsort gibt es
nicht aber die bundeswehrkräfte befanden
sich rund 180 kilometer nördlich des
deutschen lagers in gohr in den
morgenstunden zündete ein
selbstmordattentäter ein mit sprengstoff
beladenes auto zwölf deutsche und ein un
soldat wurden verletzt drei davon schwer
sie werden alle verständnis dafür haben
dass sich unsere ganze kraft jetzt vor
allen dingen darauf konzentriert die
verwundeten gute versorgung
schnellstmöglich nach hause zu bringen
aber auch alle anderen soldatinnen und
soldaten vom anschlagsort sicher nachbau
zurückzubringen seit 2013 beteiligt sich
die bundeswehr an der un-mission - marc
kern aufgabe ist die überwachung der
waffenruhe zwischen den malischen
konfliktparteien der anschlag zeigt noch
einmal auf traurige weise dass unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten im zweifel mit
ihrem leben einstehen für ihren auftrag
und für ihren dienst und das auch die
lage in mali sehr gefährlich ist
tatsächlich ist molly seit jahren
politisch instabil dschihadisten und
regionale milizen greifen zunehmend auch
internationale truppen an die
linkspartei fordert nach dem anschlag
konsequenzen wir sind aufgefordert über
alle einsätze sehr grundsätzlich neu
nachzudenken und ich wünsche mir dass
der nächste bundestag hier sehr solide
neue entscheidungen trifft
tatsächlich dürfte die diskussion wieder
aufflammen denn die mission - meist mit
fast 250 todesopfern der gefährlichste
einsatz der vereinten nationen
fragen wir unseren korrespondenten in
berlin theo koll hat dieser anschlag
konsequenzen für den bundeswehr einsatz
ja ich glaube davon ist auszugehen denn
er fügt sich ein in eine größere ja
schon laufende politische debatte da ist
einerseits die frage der bewaffnung der
soldaten also hätten beispielsweise
bewaffnete drohnen oder andere
sicherheitsmaßnahmen die soldaten
stärker schützen können die bundeswehr
wird jetzt prüfen ob etwas den anschlag
hätte verhindern können und dann könnte
sich die frage nach bewaffneten drohnen
die ja eigentlich im koalitionsvertrag
der gruppe vereinbart waren auch der
nächsten bundesregierung stellen und
insgesamt die frage ob das mandat
robuster sein muss oder zu beenden ist
und andererseits stellt sich die frage
nach dem konzept des deutschen einsatzes
was soll bis wann eigentlich erreicht
werden diese angestrebte stabilisierung
marlies ist jedenfalls nicht erreicht
worden und die sicherheitslage
verschlimmert sich immer weiter
frankreich hat schon klar gemacht dass
es nicht mehr als einzige die noch
gefährlichere terrorbekämpfung
übernehmen will also all diese debatten
dürfte der heutige anschlag noch
intensivieren dankeschön nach berlin
theo koll und
soeben erreichen uns meldungen aus
würzburg dort es zu einem
gewaltverbrechen gekommen
medienberichten mit verweis auf die
polizei von drei toten und sechs
verletzten bei einem amoklauf die
innenstadt ist weiträumig abgesperrt
eine gefahr für die bevölkerung bestehe
nicht mehr der mit einem messer
bewaffnete täter möglicherweise ein
geistig verwirrter mann ist offenbar
außer gefecht gesetzt und festgenommen
hintergründe sind noch unklar
sollten weitere details bekannt werden
informieren wir sie in dieser sendung
nach tschechien wo gestern abend ein
tornado wütete und zwar so heftig wie
man es sonst eher aus den usa kennt die
ortschaften trümmerfelder mindestens
fünf menschen starben dutzende wurden
verletzt all das geschah im
dreiländereck mit österreich und der
slowakei in der region südmähren was der
tornado auf seinem weg durch mehrere
dörfer rund um morawski nova ves
anrichtete zeigt wolf christian ullrich
es sind bilder des schreckens der
verwüstung der zerstörung
der tornado hat ganze häuser in ruinen
verwandelt autos durch den ort
geschleudert und den menschen von
morawski nova ves die heimat genommen
das ganze innerhalb von wenigen minuten
es war wie ein blitz so schnell hat er
alles auf der straße mitgerissen in
meiner straße hat keiner mehr ein dach
wir sind dem tod nur um sekunden
entronnen es ging alles rasend schnell
so sah der tornado aus die menschen
haben ihn gefilmt wie er sich näherte
und in die häuser eindringt
sofort nach dem unwetter begannen die
rettungsmaßnahmen über 100
feuerwehreinheiten sowie rettungskräfte
aus tschechien österreich und der
slowakei waren die ganze nacht über im
einsatz
ich bin hier feuerwehrmann wir haben nur
zwei stunden geschlafen
damit wir hier helfen
fünf tote zählen die behörden heute und
mehr als 60 verletzte in den
krankenhäusern
zehn von ihnen in kritischem zustand
der regional gouverneur spricht von der
hölle auf erden
jetzt suchen sie in den trümmern nach
ihren habseligkeiten in tschechien ist
bereit seine große spendenaktion
angelaufen essens lieferungen für die
betroffenen gemeinden sind auf den weg
der tornado hat mehreren dörfern die
existenzgrundlage entzogen
ich habe eine firma alles ist kaputt ich
muss weg und mich kümmern sagt dieser
mann noch und läuft weiter der sturm ist
vorüber doch der albtraum der menschen
von borowski nova ves wird noch lange
weitergehen
peter hippe ist für uns im
katastrophengebiet britta wir gehen die
aufräumarbeiten voran
beeindruckend schnell muss man sagen
aber es ist auch noch eine große menge
zu tun in diesem 4000 seelen ort hier
morast hannover west zum beispiel hat im
zentrum praktisch jedes haus mindestens
einen tag verloren inklusive der kirche
1300 feuerwehrleute sind im einsatz 300
soldaten von der armee und sogar die
förster haben ja schweres gerät
geschickt aber nun hat man die
freiwilligen gebeten besser zu hause zu
bleiben die vielen freiwilligen die
kommen wollten denn die seien von dieser
situation vor schlicht überfordert die
hilfsbereitschaft ist riesig die
tschechen haben selber schon über drei
millionen euro gespendet und wir sehen
immer wieder menschen die kleidung
bringen wasser verpflegung decken und
zelte denn tatsächlich wird es wohl
manchen leuten schwer fallen heute nacht
in ihrem eigenen haus übernachten
eindrücke live aus dem
katastrophengebiet in tschechien vielen
dank britta hilpert
warum war dieser tornado so heftig und
müssen wir uns darauf einstellen dass
auch bei uns in europa solche unwetter
zu nehmen luton leyen muss hat antworten
ein monster tornado wie in tschechien
noch nicht erlebt hat und der rasend
schnell über die menschen kam wir hatten
es mit einem tief zu tun seit gestern
das quasi sich angenähert hatte und hat
diese gewitter ausgelöst und die sind in
kurzer zeit hoch geschossen wie popcorn
quasi in die höhe und hat starkregen
hagel und eben auch so an tornado
produziert und das passiert so heißt es
da eine mächtige gewitterwolken feuchte
und warme luft steigt nach oben wo es
kälter ist und ein starker wind aus
einer anderen richtung weht diese wind
scherung verwirbelt die luft zu einem
aufwind schlauch die feuchtigkeit darin
kondensiert und setzt noch mehr energie
frei erreicht dieser wolken brüssel den
boden wird er zum tornado
bisher war solche zerstörungskraft in
unseren breiten selten die erderwärmung
ändert das wärmere luft ist eben
zündstoff für diese gewitter dieser
starken gewitter je wärmer es ist desto
mehr feuchtigkeit kann die luft
aufnehmen und diese wärme diese energie
wird frei wenn es dann zur gewitter zur
wolkenbildung kommt und dann zu heftigen
gewittern eben gegeben hat des tornados
immer schon auch bei uns doch der
klimawandel macht sie stärker
anderes thema jetzt corona da fordert
gesundheitsminister sparen die menschen
eindringlich auf ihren termin zur
zweitimpfung wahrzunehmen
zwar geht die sieben tage incidents
weiter nach unten
6,2 ist der wert heute vor einer woche
lag noch bei 10,3 trotzdem die warnung
die zuerst in indien entdeckte delta
variante des virus verbreitet sich auch
bei uns immer stärker nach jüngsten
erkenntnissen
15 prozent aller neuen fälle infektionen
mit der data variante heike slansky
am hamburger hafen wurden heute erstmals
seeleute aus aller welt geimpft in
deutschland genießt inzwischen jeder
dritte den vollständigen schutz jeder
zweite hat bereits eine erste impfung
erhalten trotzdem verhaltene optimismus
beim gesundheitsminister wir dürfen
zuversichtlich in diesem sommer gehen
wir können den sommer genießen aber eben
mit vorsicht aus einem zu sorglosen
sommer darf kein sorgen herbst werden
trotz niedriger instanzen breite sich
die neue delta variante aus sie treffe
häufig jüngere meist auch härter viele
müssten ins krankenhaus
wir sehen bei vergleichbaren
altersgruppen die infiziert sind das bei
der delta variante momentanen stand
vorgestern elf prozent derjenigen die
infiziert wurden werden hospitalisiert
die mit delta infiziert wurden im
vergleichs raum wurden fünf prozent
derjenigen hospitalisiert die mit alpha
infiziert wurden deshalb gelte weiterhin
auch für diejenigen die es im sommer in
die ferne zieht testen abstand maske
gegen eine vierte welle helfe nur eine
möglichst hohe impfquote für ältere mit
abgeschwächten immunsystem wird über
eine auffrischung nachgedacht die daten
sollten wir ernst nehmen und uns schon
einmal darauf vorbereiten dass für
bestimmte personengruppen im herbst und
winter gegebenenfalls eine
auffrischungsimpfung notwendig werden
könnte die virus gefahr sei noch nicht
gebannt der appell heute nicht die
zweitimpfung verstreichen lassen denn
nur die schütze vor allem gegen die
delta variante
die warnung vor der delta variante
nehmen offenbar viele bereits sehr ernst
zwei drittel rechnen mit einer vierten
corona welle im herbst das ist eines der
ergebnisse des aktuellen politbarometers
auch die aktuellen maßnahmen finden eine
mehrheit markus töpfer fasst zusammen
was können beim einkaufen seit
mittlerweile 14 monaten ständige
begleiter und das soll auch so bleiben
sagen 79 prozent der befragten für
öffentliche verkehrsmittel finden dass
sogar 87 prozent der blick auf die
bundestagswahl im september bringt kaum
veränderungen die union käme auf 29
prozent spd auf 14 afd und fdp auf 10
linke auf 7 und die grünen auf 22
prozent doch das muss nicht so bleiben
80 prozent der befragten glauben dass
noch nicht klar ist wer die
bundestagswahl am ende gewinnt die
meisten erwarten allerdings dass die
union das rennen machen wird nur neun
prozent sehen die grünen ins kanzleramt
einziehen auch im direkten vergleich
liegt grünen-kandidatin annalena
baerbock hinten die meisten sprechen
sich für unions kandidat armin laschet
aus
noch mehr spannende zahlen vom
politbarometer sehen sie wie immer im
heute journal um 22 uhr und jederzeit
online auf heute.de
nach brüssel zum wahrscheinlich letzten
großen eu-gipfel mit angela merkel war
am nachmittag mit einem misserfolg für
die kanzlerin endete ihr vorschlag auf
europäischer ebene ein gesprächsformat
mit russland zu finden wurde abgelehnt
ziemlich einig war sich die runde
dagegen in ihrer heftigen kritik an
ungarn wegen des umstrittenen
homosexuellen gesetzes anne gellinek
berichtet am morgen danach ist viktor
orban in der eu gipfelrunde ein einsamer
mann niemand stellt sich zu ihm die
debatte der langen nacht wirkt nach gut
zwei stunden lang hatten die 27 staats
und regierungschefs und chefinnen über
das ungarische gesetz zur sexuellen
minderheiten über toleranz und europas
werte diskutiert so offen wie selten
zuvor sogar vom austritt ungarns war die
rede
das war eine beeindruckende diskussion
ich habe es noch nie erlebt dass
regierungschefs einander so hart angehen
wegen der situation in einem land
steckt diese diskussion ist natürlich
nicht beendet sie war aber ehrlich und
ich glaube auch wichtig man müsse das
gesetz zurücknehmen fordert eine klare
mehrheit andernfalls solle die eu
kommission ungarn vom europäischen
gerichtshof verklagen
nicht weniger hitzig die debatte über
russland merkel und marc hatten wieder
direkte treffen der europäer mit
russlands präsidenten punkten
vorgeschlagen doch sie scheiterten am
widerstand der osteuropäer die idee
komme zum falschen zeitpunkt ich will
ausdrücklich sagen dass sich solche
gespräche mit dem russischen präsidenten
nicht in der form von belohnung oder
nicht belohnungs sehe sondern ich glaube
dass wir uns darauf besinnen müssen das
auch im kalten krieg immer
gesprächskanäle da waren am ende einigt
man sich auf eine härtere gangart bei
wirtschaftssanktionen von einem
eu-gipfel mit putin aber ist keine rede
mehr eine niederlage für angela merkel
die die befindlichkeiten von
osteuropäern und balten falsch
eingeschätzt hat zudem war der vorschlag
schlecht vorbereitet viele
gipfel-teilnehmer fühlten sich
überrumpelt und so endet der wohl letzte
eu gipfel der kanzlerin mit krach und
kontroverse
monate lang wurde in der eu auch über
die agrarpolitik erbittert gestritten
vor allem über die frage wie viel von
den fördergeldern soll an umweltauflagen
geknüpft werden jetzt die einigung
insgesamt geht es um 270 milliarden euro
für die jahre 2003 und 20 bis 27
bis zu einem viertel werden jetzt an
sogenannte öko regeln geknüpft dass eben
parlament und umweltverbände hatten
deutlich mehr gefordert
der bundestag hat kurz vor der
sommerpause noch zahlreiche wichtige
gesetze beschlossen so kann stalking
jetzt schon schneller und härter
geahndet werden auch im netz außerdem
soll es künftig einfacher sein verträge
für handytarife streaming dienste oder
fitnessstudios zu kündigen und städte
und gemeinden mit mehr als 50.000
einwohnern müssen einen mietspiegel
erstellen das soll vor überzogenen
mieterhöhungen schützen
billigfleisch verkaufen discounter
bislang mit dem argument der kunde wolle
es nun mal haben nun erklärt aldi das
bewusstsein der kunden habe sich
gewandelt ab 2030 will man nur noch
fleisch aus besseren haltungsformen
anbieten also von tieren die einen
gewissen platz und auslauf haben der
tierschutzbund finde es gut und hofft
dass andere folgen alko rams hat details
billigfleisch zu erkennen an der 1 oder
2 auf der verpackung hier sind die
haltungsbedingungen für die tiere am
schlechtesten jetzt wollen aldi nord und
süd diese stufen abschaffen bis 2030
stellen wir vollständig auf die
haltungsform drei eine tierhaltung mit
zugangs frischluft und außen klima und
auf die haltungsform 4 die
vollumfängliche biohaltung kommen ein
ehrgeiziges ziel denn schließlich
stammen 90 prozent des verkauften
schweinefleisches bei aldi so das
unternehmen
aus den niedrigen haltung stufen um die
bedingungen für die tiere zu verbessern
müssen viele ställe umgebaut werden dazu
gehören offene fenster und
beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten für die
schweine das kostet die
landwirtschaftlichen betriebe müssten
massiv investieren hohe kosten
bewältigen und das hieße sie bräuchten
deutlich höhere preise mit ein paar sind
mehrpreis ist es nicht getan
auch andere lebensmittel einzelhändler
haben angekündigt das billigfleisch
schrittweise aus den regalen zu nehmen
kritiker sind gespannt wie die
einzelhändler ihre ziele erreichen
wollen
wenn man bedenkt welche
widerstände zum teil da noch überwunden
werden müssen auf seiten der
landwirtschaft beim baurecht und
ähnlichen dingen ist das glaube ich
schon sehr ambitioniert dann tatsächlich
bis 2030 das programm entsprechend
umzusetzen
klar ist dass das fleisch in zukunft bei
vielen einzelhändlern teurer wird dann
muss ich wohl auch der verbraucher um
stehe
nach florida nach dem einsturz eines
hochhauses nördlich von miami beach
suchen rettungskräfte weiter nach
überlebenden unter meter hohen trümmern
sollen immer wieder klopfgeräusche zu
hören sein spürhunde und spezialkameras
werden eingesetzt die zahl der toten ist
auf vier gestiegen
159 menschen gelten weiterhin als
vermisst
das zwölf stücke die wohngebäude war
gestern aus unbekannter ursache
teilweise eingestürzt
jetzt zur fußball-em norbert am dienstag
ist das achtelfinale england gegen
deutschland im legendären londoner
wembley stadion vor
45.000 zuschauern darunter wohl nur ein
paar tausend deutsche anhänger wegen der
strengen quarantänevorschriften schaffen
des fans aus deutschland nicht mehr
rechtzeitig zum spiel deshalb haben nur
in großbritannien lebende deutsche die
chance dabei zu sein
für das spiel im wembley stadion hätten
laut englischen medienberichten 10.000
tickets für deutsche zur verfügung
gestanden jetzt werden es weit weniger
in die arena schaffen aber auch vor ort
gibt es viele interessierte fans es gibt
eine facebook-gruppe deutsche in london
und da habe ich durch zufall gesehen
dass jemand geschrieben hat man kann den
dfb anschreiben weil es noch tickets
gibt für deutsche die in uk bohnen und
das habe ich dann sofort gemacht das
beispiel sankt petersburg zeigt wie
wichtig corona vorsichtsmaßnahmen sind
nach dem spiel finnland gegen belgien
sind bisher 86 infektionen bei
finnischen rückkehrern aus russland
festgestellt worden
der neue fußball bundesliga spielplan
steht fest zur saison eröffnung gibt es
echte traditionsduell meister bayern
münchen tritt am 13 august bei borussia
mönchengladbach an und in der zweiten
liga trifft bereits am 23 juli schalke
04 auf den hamburger sv
ja ein wirklich anstrengender
wettkampftag beim wta turnier in bad
homburg wegen wetterkapriolen die
viertel und halbfinals an einem einzigen
tag die deutsche nummer eins angelique
kerber spielt zur stunde im halbfinale
nachdem sie zuvor am mittag erfolgreich
war
angelique kerber tanz selbstvertrauen
für das am montag beginnende turnier in
wimbledon sie verlor zwar den ersten
satz gegen die amerikanerin amanda
anissimow war im weiteren verlauf jedoch
kam die derzeit weltranglisten 28 aus
kiel immer besser ins spiel
der match war nach gut eineinhalb
stunden kerber gewinnt mit 2 6 6 3 und 6
3 und bestreitet nun das halbfinale
gegen die an nummer eins gesetzte
tschechin petra kvitova
das was am sport danke schön und wir
schauen noch mal zurück zum amoklauf in
würzburg es gab offenbar drei tote und
sechs verletzte die polizei bestätigt
nun es besteht keine gefahr mehr es gebe
keine hinweise auf weitere täter mehr
dazu in all unseren nachrichtensendungen
und jederzeit auf zdf heute
beim wetter kehrt vorübergehend ruhe ein
und die hitze zurück mehr dazu gleich
von osten terry um 22 uhr begrüßt sie
christian sievers im heute journal als
sicher mit aktuellen berichten zu
würzburg wir danken ihnen für interesse
wünschen ein schönes wochenende und
sagen tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter auf unseren
satelliten film der letzten 24 stunden
sehen sie rote farbkleckse das sind
gewitter und schauen sie mal hier
richtung tschechien wie das da hoch
schießt und in diesem bereich gab es
diesen verheerenden tornado gestern über
tschechien ja und auch im süden
deutschlands gab es heute wiederum
gewitter aber die lassen der kommenden
nacht relativ rasch nach und sind noch
einige schauer dann unterwegs ansonsten
ist es trocken im süden klart es auf
dort gehen die temperaturen bis auf 9
grad zurück ähnlich im hessischen
bergland 15 grad gibt es an der nordsee
morgen erstmal viel sonnenschein und
dann gibt es zwei zentren einmal
richtung erzgebirge und richtung emsland
da gibt es schauer und gewitter einzelne
schauer und auch mal mit blitz und
donner kann es in den mittelgebirgen
generell geben und auch an den alpen bei
temperaturen bis 27 grad am oberrhein
und im osten 21 grad im vogtland und an
der nordsee am sonntag gibt es
badewetter pur bis 30 grad am montag
wird zwar noch heiser aber von westen
erreichen uns wieder heftige gewitter
und die setzten sich am dienstag fort
bis 32 grad damit ein schöner ab